[موسيقى]
بسرا احنا كنا في بلوك 12 من بلوك 12 رحنا
على الاواء اللي في بلوك تسعه بعد الاواء
جينا هنا بعونا يعني حطونا مناشير مناشير
ورحلنا الاماكن هذه الاماكن هذه ننا بنعيش
في حياه صعبه ان شاء الله ربنا يهدي البال
وترجع الامور زي اول واحسن ان شاء الله اه
وضعنا احنا عايشين في صعب يعني شوف مشردين
ببيوتنا ه بخيم حتى الان بستنى يعملوا لنا
بخيم بخيم ومعنا اطفال منعاني يعني كمان
من حاجات ثانيه حتى الحليب مش قادرين يجيب
لاولادنا الوضع صعب طحين اي حاجه اي شي
يطلعنا الله بيعلم ما معناش ولا شيكل
والله اللي صار معان يا شيخ قبل شهر
ونص قبل شهر ونص صار عنا قصف وطلعنا على
المدرسه وطلعنا على المدرسه ومن المدرسه
طبعا يما رموا
المناشير الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه اخلوا وخلينا يشوفوا حال
هالشعب ايش صار فيه شوف الاطفال كلهم مرضه
كل الاطفال مرضه كل مرضه ابني امبارح قعد
في المستشفى يومين وبنت بنت ابني عيانه
مرت ابني عيانه كيف ل زي ما انت شايف انا
كنت في غزه عن المسلخ الجديد قالوا لي
اطلعي رحنا على ضنا العتيقه عند جامع
الشمعه بعدين قالوا لي اطلع من جامع
الشمعه رحت عند اهلي في البريج قعدت شهر
لما قالوا البريج مهدده اطلع اجن انا على
در البلح والله متنا من خوف من
قصف اول ما طلعنا من دورنا رحنا على مدرسه
مدرسه ابو عاصي اللي في الشمالي وقعدنا
بيجي اسبوعين ورموا علينا اليهود قنابل
غاز عشان نطلع من المكان فرحنا وين رحنا
على الشفا وفي الشفا برضه نفس نفس الشيء
ضربوا قسم الولاده وطلعوا منها هناك من
هناك شهداء اطفال صغار طلعنا على مخيم ارض
المفتي النصيرات قعدنا هناك في مدرسه
ورموا علينا مناشير توجهوا الى تل السلطان
الى رفح اجينا هان اجينا هان وهينا نصبنا
شو اسمه الخشب ولسه بنستنى بالخيم واحنا
هنا بالمره لا اكل ولا شرب يعني بدبر حنا
تدبير وحسبنا الله وانت نعم
الوكيل